Robert Skidelsky author of John Maynard
Keynes fighting for freedom 1937 and
1946 year third of three volumes on John
Maynard Keynes you changed the title for
American audiences from fighting for
Britain to fighting for freedom why well
it was on advice I was told by a very
good English friend of mine it had a lot
of experience in publishing in the
United States that freedom goes down
well but the Britain doesn't so there
was enough truth in the in that in the
title fighting for freedom to make it
not a dishonest thing to do but he
thought it would be and my publisher
dream he thought it'd be better to leave
out Britain and put freedom as a more
general thing with which American
audiences could emphasize what well
Americans get out of this book that to
say the Brits wouldn't well I think I
think there's a lot of they'll get the
same thing roughly speaking but I
suppose that there's a sense for the
British reader that this is Britain's
last battle as a great power so to speak
and so it will create it it might create
a kind of glow for the British reader
whereas for Americans this is part of
the great struggle against evil in which
America Britain and at that point Russia
were also involved what year was this
picture taken and who are these two
people in it well that on the left as I
as I seed is Lidia Keynes Maynard
Keynes's wife and there is Keynes
himself this is a 1940 there abouts 1940
1941
he's quite slim doesn't look terribly
robust because that's after he's had his
heart attack in 1937 and say it was
taken just at the beginning of the
Second World War and just at the
beginning of his return to the British
government
he lived six more years he lived six
million 1946 how old was he when he died
he was only 62 just coming up to 63
that's my age actually I've got a few
few more days to go but he had been
unwell for a long time
he'd actually had his canary coronaries
from BOCES in 1937 which was a very
severe one and English doctors didn't
know what to do about it they just said
stay in bed and you might get better in
several years but he came in to into the
care of a brilliant Hungarian doctor
called
janosh flesh that's him and Keynes
always said he was half genius half
crank but um he he developed he he gave
Keynes a very primitive form of
antibiotic which cleared up an important
set of infections he had in his throat
and in his heart muscles and and and
this was before penicillin it was a very
early form of antibiotic called pronto
SIL and that restored Kames to life but
he couldn't cure him finally because he
couldn't get rid of all the streptococci
which was swarming around the heart
muscle but he made him well enough for
him to come back to a full-time job
in the British government in the Second
World War and work incredibly hard for
six years I am drowning in John Maynard
Keynes as the audience will see here in
just a moment there have been three
books the first one was 1883 - 1920 yes
and the second one was 1922 1937 and the
third one 1937 - 1946
give us as we would say in the United
States but cliff notes on who John
Maynard Keynes was what I mean by that
what's the short version well the short
version is that he was the greatest
economist in the 20th century even I
think Milton Friedman might accept that
he was one of the greatest economists
who taught
and he revolutionized economic theory
essentially by showing that you didn't
have to suffer mass unemployment that
you could do some governments could do
something about it
that's him at the end of his life at
Savannah and Smyrna Georgia Savannah
Georgia it's it's the launch of the
International Monetary Fund which he
helped set up and he makes a speech
there which is rather interesting he
says he was very keen on the ballet he
was married to ballerina and he says I
hope there's no malicious fairy at this
launch to wreck my mind my child that
I've just created and judge Vinson who
is the American secretary of the
Treasury thought that that remark might
be aimed at at to him and he said I
don't mind being cool malicious but I'm
damned if I'm going to be called a fairy
well that brings up another interesting
point because in the preface of your
first book early and the process you
write the following sir Roy Herod
Keynes's first biographer left out any
mention of his homosexuality and in the
premise of your very first book you go
on to say that that that's important why
did you think it was important and when
was he a homosexual well I think it's
important because I think if you're
writing a biography of someone you need
to know you need to know a lot about
their private life their purse their
character as it develops and is formed
and and Roy Harrods simply left out that
bit sexuality is a very important
component of any person's makeup and the
fact that Cain's was homosexual for the
first 30 years of his life
a his relationships were with with with
men and not women is important front to
understanding his Miglia as a young man
and and the effect it had on him and he
wasn't promiscuous he had one very big
love affair with a painter called Duncan
grant
and then once he became a more public
person in the First World War he did
move move to heterosexuality and his
marriage with Lydia likova was not in my
view a marriage of convenience by any
means it wasn't a front it was a very
very loving marriage and the very
successful marriage there were sexual
relations they did try and have children
and they amused each other the whole
time they were very very different I
think an important thing linking the two
together is that Cain's
adored artists he admired the artistic
ability very much he thought that he was
condemned to remove in the world of
affairs and not at the knot of the level
of artistic inspiration I I disagree I
think he was an artist in economics but
he admired people who could paint who
could write the Bloomsbury group many of
them were his friends Virginia Woolf e/m
Forster and and these are the people he
admired and and he he he loved he came
to love in his life to artist Duncan
grant who is a painter and Lydia lapa
koba who was one of the great ballerinas
of the early twentieth century how many
people knew back in his time that he was
a homosexual not that many his own
circle of friends that he had met at
Cambridge and and people in the
Bloomsbury group that circle of painters
and artists and friends but not the
world outside and they kept it quiet
because at that time it was illegal
there was a there was under British law
homosexual relations were were forbidden
and if court you could be sent to prison
as indeed Oscar Wilde had been only you
know when Cannes was a teenager so they
were careful but he didn't go prowling
around and you know I think
was all kept within the group but you
actually got love letters in here
between Duncan grant and John Maynard
Keynes yeah and who's the other fellow
Linton's rachey who is letting
straighten well little straight she was
one of the great biographers of this
century his he he wrote a book called
eminent Victorians which revolutionized
the art of biography short very sharp
ironic sketches of great Victorians not
those three volume things well I
shouldn't say that I've just written
three volumes it shows Lytton Strachey
perhaps haven't been as influential as
he thought but he was he was a he was a
frank biographer and and he was
particularly interested in the
psychology of other people who wrote
about Florence Nightingale General
Gordon some of these Victorians who had
all been placed on a pedestal a little
demonstrate she pricked them with da
little little flashes of irony and so
that became particular style of
biography a debunking style you might
you might call it he was a great friend
of maynard keynes they they met as
undergraduates of cambridge and they
went on being friends all through life
but they did fight over one or two young
male beautiful young men you've got a
letter here from November I mean August
of 1908 from John Maynard Keynes who
they called what what was his person
well they called him usually may not but
they also his nickname was pop so
because they thought his conversation
wasn't very suitable and no one quite
knows what pot so means but it is the
Italian for a drain I think who called
him that listen Lytton Strachey was
always make your nickname nickname his
friends but his actual given names were
John Maynard in this letter August 5th
1908 from John Maynard Keynes to Duncan
grant dear Duncan I love you too much I
can't now bear to live without you how
did you find that letter well it's in
it's in the Keynes it's in the Keynes
letters
they kept everything these people they
kept all their letters they were
convinced that one day they would be
published and and and they wanted the
world to know what they were like but
not then they didn't want them to be
published instantly and so these
particular letters of Keynes to Duncan
grant were kept by Duncan grant and I
saw them in the British Library in
London when I started doing my research
go back to the this Roy Herod Roy Herod
in 1951 yeah wrote a biography on John
Maynard Keynes and you say he never
mentioned any of us now why did he not
do that I think it was understandable at
the time Keynes had been dead for six
years five years when the biography came
out he was a great hero to the British
he had you know he was a world statesman
by this time
first of all Herod didn't want that bit
of it to be known and especially he
didn't want the Americans to know
because he thought that would damage the
influence of Keynes in the United States
secondly he didn't want his widow he
didn't want you know lady Keynes was
still alive very much alive and he
didn't want all that coming out and she
would have been very upset probably
whether she would have been upset or not
I don't know really she was a very
broad-minded character and probably knew
all about it but whether she would have
wanted it coming out so discretion was
the better part of valor I think where I
don't blame Herod for that what I think
he was where I think he was wrong was to
imply that he had told the whole story
he should have really said look not
everything can be told about this person
after six years
you'll have to wait for another twenty
or thirty years you tell us that he went
to Eton and that he went to Cambridge
and that he was an apostle yeah that he
became a lord that he was at the
Treasury Whitehall working for the
government but never held an official
position he
ever held an official position well he
held an official position of the
Treasury both in the First World War
where he was actually a career he was he
he entered the career structure of the
Treasury in the Second World War he was
semi-detached adviser to the chance for
the Exchequer
he never held an official position he
was often asked to stand for Parliament
if he had been if he had got into
Parliament he would almost certainly
have been Chancellor of the Exchequer
that his secretary of the Treasury
without any doubt at some point in his
life but he preferred to remain free a
free spirit
he had his base at Cambridge he read his
books he was consulted by governments
but he prefer he wants to keep his
independence what was his biggest book
his biggest book was the general theory
of employment interest and money which
was published in 1936 and that was the
revolutionary book so he wrote it in
1936 before World War two started yeah
and is there waited to answer this
question had he not been alive had he
not published his books how would we be
different in this country um well I
think that had he not been alive and
published his books America would have
had a much more stormy economic progress
after the Second World War
I'm not saying the Great Depression
would have recurred I think that was
probably a one-off event but the economy
would have been much more volatile and
the reason it's been fairly smooth and
there haven't been that many real
serious nothing like the Great
Depression and not really any very very
serious recession since the Second World
War is largely because of John Maynard
Keynes governments knew that they had to
take some action to offset depressive
forces when they developed and they and
they did that all through the post-war
period now it sometimes went wrong and
the downside of Keynesianism was that
you could get into inflation in really
serious inflationary problems
I don't think that was entirely his
fault but it was partly as full what
does it mean to be a Keynesian to be a
Keynesian means that you first of all
you believe that governments can make
can improve the performance of an
economy the level of growth and
employment in the economy by certain
measures by monetary policy and by
fiscal policy let me just stop you to
ask you this when we hear our folks in
this country say leaders say that full
employment is four percent unemployment
is that a Keynesian statement absolutely
Keynes never believed that full
employment was zero
he believed that full employment was
what you could achieve without running
into serious other problems like if you
try to get it below for employment
you'll probably get into an inflationary
inflationary situation so he he thought
full employment was about four percent
and that's what the post-war Keynesian
the American post-war Keynesian believed
that roughly the United States was doing
okay when employment was four percent if
it was about five percent there was some
unused capacity in the economy people
were unnecessarily unemployed and
therefore your your economy was
suffering and you could do something
about that by cutting taxes spending a
bit more money or reducing interest
rates applying wage in price controls
like Richard Nixon did back in the 70s
is that a Keynesian move cane has never
advocated that himself
that was what Keynesian were finally
driven to in desperation I think the per
the Keynes ins of the time I think they
because whenever they tried to get
unemployment down to about four percent
or something by this time in the 1960s
they found that inflation was starting
to rise and they thought they could
clamp down on inflation by having these
wage and price control
what Keynes would have said about their
efforts I'm not sure something he might
have said is that you're aiming for too
low a level of unemployment and you
should allow unemployment to rise a bit
I don't know you know this is one of
those questions what would Keynes have
said had he been alive today he would
have been a different man he would have
grown up on the different economic and
political circumstances who knows what
he would have said but wage wage and
price controls though they were called
Keynesian were never actually advocated
by Keynes where do you live on a
full-time basis on a full-time basis I
divide my life between London and East
Sussex and whereas ends up in England
where is it on the coast it's very near
Brighton it's sort of very close to the
English Channel and you teach where I
teach where I no longer teach actually I
used to be professor in the economics
department at Warwick University
Warwick universities in England and in
the last few years
I'm sanster I've still got a chair in
that department but I don't have to
teach any longer are you an economist
are you a historian I like to call
myself an economically literate
historian because I was trained first of
all as a historian I did study at
economics but it was not my I did never
took a degree in economics I never did
postgraduate work in economics I
understand economic arguments up to a
point I think I do anyway and therefore
I saw wear two hats and to write about
Keynes without trying to learn economics
would have been a disaster now you got
the Lionel gareb alag Albert Dell Prize
winner of 2001 what is that award
engraver that's well that's not a
British award actually that's a Canadian
award and yeah it's that little lads
little girls
go bit on the cover and that's for
international relations that's that's
reckoned to be the best book I am told
in international relations published in
in the in the relevant year which was
last year are you Acadian I'm a I'm a
reconstructed Keynesian that's to say
I don't think he was right about
everything there are certain things
really that he there's certain ways in
which she would have amended his theory
in the light of further experience no
doubt at all about that I think he was
very over optimistic about the capacity
of governments to keep politics out of
their economic policy I think he was yes
I think that's probably the main the
main thing where he was a bit naive on
the political side of things and and
we've also learnt there's certain things
he didn't say which people like Milton
Friedman said which were very very
important they weren't exactly anti
Keynesian they came out as anti
Keynesian because Keynesianism was the
reigning orthodoxy of the 1960s and
there were these high priests Paul
Samuelson James Tobin the Council of
Economic Advisers and anyone who sort of
made any criticism of what they were
doing almost had to say you know this is
an T Keynes Milton Friedman said that he
regards Keynes as the greatest economy
is one of the great economists of all
time that he asked many of the right
questions he had some of the right
answer not all of them but you know the
world moves on and there are certain
things he didn't get that seems
reasonable you know no one has said that
no one has the last word in wisdom
however great the thinker is have you
heard his voice yes have you seen any
video of him in yes video yes I have he
appeared on television once or twice it
was very early days a television he
sorry
when I say television i I mean newsreel
because television was only just
starting in the thirties I've seen him
on newsreel excuse your period I've had
television in Britain before we had here
like after say 30 I think 39th outdated
yes
no there was television first two first
television I'm aware of in Britain first
showing was about 1931 1932 is that
before the United States well they had
an experimental
they didn't really get into it here and
well they didn't really get into it in
Harry laughter the war actually but
there were there were one or two bits
but keynes appeared in 1931 when britain
went off the gold standard this was
considered an absolutely catastrophic
event in the economic history of the
time britain left the gold standard and
they had keynes explaining why Britain
had left for those standard and why it
was a good thing because this would give
Britain freedom to do something about
unemployment to reduce interest rates
what he found like what's he look like
London edit dead um and I've also heard
him speaking what does he sound like he
sounds like an upper-class Englishman
rather Daanish academic of that time
maybe that's how I sound like I don't
know a funny here now I mean he wasn't
funny on the newsreel you weren't
expected to be funny and it was a somber
event and therefore you expected to be
very serious and suitably serious on his
broadcasts he he is a bit funny I mean
he he makes he doesn't make jokes then
they don't roll around the aisles
spitting your sides but he he makes some
ironic subtle subtle remarks would you
like him personally yes how do you like
me you have a picture in here of a man
that is well-known in this country by
people who study history and here's that
here's the picture of the two of them
together Harry Dexter white yeah that's
right that was accused of being a
communist years against there at
Atlantic City then and that's just
before breaking with the Bretton Woods
conference which sets up the
International Monetary Fund it that that
photograph is taken in in jus July 1944
and what about this photograph he's not
in it but Mr Blair yeah mr. Morgan
taught Keynes always used to use to talk
about his dreadful smirk it fell on the
right
yeah the fellow on the right Henry
Morgenthau secretary of the Treasury
Keynes his great sparring partner during
the Second World War and I put dr. Koon
on the left I just thought it was good
to have him in because as I said the
bottom he never missed a photo
opportunity was he he was the finance
minister
China and what was John Maynard Keynes's
involvement in the whole lend-lease
issue and what was lend-lease well then
lease was the way America help Britain
stay in the war it was it was it was not
alone it was a grant to Britain they
basically supplied Britain free of
charge with many of the war materials
and also civilian materials they needed
to go on fighting because Britain was
running out of gold to pay for what it
had to import from the United States in
order to stay in the war this is World
War two this is World War two and in
1941 Roosevelt he said the Americans
were submitted by the neutrality acts
from lending money to Britain to lending
money to any belligerent any country
that was fighting and and and even more
so lending to any country that had
defaulted on its debt first world war
debt as Britain had done finally in 1931
so there was no way the Americans could
send supplies to Britain unless Britain
paid for them Britain ran out of money
early in 1941 and Roosevelt conjured up
this idea that they'd sort of lend lend
Britain supplies with the idea that they
would come back to Britain and come back
to America after the war that was
fictional obviously you'd enter you
using up your munitions there's nothing
to return but he got it through Congress
that way and and so that was a virtual
thought that was an act of greatly
extraordinary generosity as indeed it
was but on the other hand I say in my
book America needed Britain to keep
fighting then say it was an act of
self-defense why did I reckon either
because of the fact the British control
the Atlantic and if Britain went under
and the Germans got control of the
Atlantic then they will they would that
much nearer the United States with their
submarines and they could stop sinking
things and then the balance of power in
latin america they were wanted to
pro-nazi
fascist leaders like Perron in in
Argentina so it was a it was sold by
Roosevelt as an act of self-defense when
he when he when he did his lend-lease
act he said by keeping Britain in the
war
our boys won't have to fight that's what
he actually said of course that turned
out not to be true but then the
Americans had catched certain conditions
to lend-lease it wasn't alone said well
there weren't repayment conditions but
conditions about what Britain should do
about its economic system and its trade
relations after the war that the British
found unfair and rather onerous and they
tried to wriggle out of them but that
was the plot of anglo-american relations
during the second world war set by
lend-lease and the way lend-lease was
conceived and and and and implement what
was John Maynard Keynes rollin on well
John Maynard Keynes came to America
first came to Washington in 1941 the
first time as head of a British mission
to clear up some of the details of the
lend-lease appropriations what Britain
should be getting and there he was in
Washington in 1941 and that's when he
started getting to know Morgan tour the
Secretary of Treasury and that's when he
also started his long relationship with
Harry Dexter white who was more than
tours assistant secretary and Morgan
tour really trusted Harry Dexter white
and said I wanted all in one brain and
that's Harry White's brain and and then
said that he came to Washington 1941
there's a rather funny story when he
first came out came to the Treasury one
of the US Treasury one of the officials
said them where's your lawyer and Kane
said we haven't brought a lawyer and and
the guy said well who's going to do your
thinking for you then and Keynes always
said that America was a country run by
lawyers he always thought that ask what
is Harry Dexter white image today
not great I think that there's still a
bit of a debate about it but I think
it's a languishing debate he was a very
very able man Harry Dexter white very
constructive mind big thinking he was
Pro communist and he was there not a
member of the Communist Party ever and
he was I think almost certainly a Soviet
agent he was one of a group of people in
the Treasury who passed on information
to the Soviet Union and that was alleged
in 1940 in in the war itself by
Elizabeth Bentley and Whittaker Chambers
among others they both independently
told told the FBI that Harry White was
was passing information to the Russians
there was no smoking gun except their
testimony but the Americans have since
and decrypted a lot of the messages
passing from the Soviet Union to United
States through their embassies and
through the trade mission in New York
which show I think that Harry White was
one of the Soviet agents he was regarded
as one of our greatest assets as they
said and there's now so much testimony
coming in from so many different sources
that I don't think it's in doubt any
longer there are one or two people who
still argue for the fact yes he was
seeing the Soviets but that was by way
of his official duties and the Soviet
Union was an ally and he didn't really
go beyond what was allowable for a US
official but I don't think that washes
extras of word by where did you go to
school I went to school in England I
went to school with Brighton college we
mentioned earlier Eton yep how did
Maynard Keynes go to Eton and what is it
Eton is probably the most famous school
in the world I don't think that's just
British British Chauvin is and I think
it's probably the best-known
it's it's it's the leading private
school in England we call them public
schools but it's the leading private
school in England the most famous
founded in the 15th century very
beautiful of very lots of old buildings
very near Windsor which is where which
is one of the homes of the British
monarch and it was it was a sort of the
monarchy always had a close connection
with Eton and there he went as a scholar
they had a they had them they had a one
section of the school was called college
and it was scholarship boys by 1900
these scholarship boys were not poor
boys they hadn't been intended for poor
scholars but most of them were pretty
well-off only they were extremely brainy
what year do you go to Eton hey you you
start at 13 how long you stay there 4 or
5 years now now maybe more for than five
no five years is probably average and
how many it is still only boys still
only boys yes how many go there there
about a thousand in the school now they
live in the palms and have they have
their own houses which are run by house
masters but the brainy ones have one
house who on their own which is called
college and they still wear funny
clothes tales and you know right yeah
white eyes they look a bit like waiters
and on formal formal occasions they wear
top hats and he went there for four
years five years and how did what kind
of family did he come from he came from
a family of university teachers really
it was a Victorian success story their
pool pulled themselves up by their
bootstraps
they were nonconformist his grandfather
started quite a as a poor not very rich
person but he made money as a
businessman in in in in flowers he was
he was a
he cultivated he was a market gardener
and he made quite a lot of money and his
son who was very bright Maynard Keynes's
father passed a whole lot of scholarship
exams and got into Cambridge and then he
became a teacher or a Don as it's called
at Cambridge University in one of the
colleges because father do his father
did and and then he married also a very
very clever lady who had also wore one
of very first few one of the first women
to enter the university though not in
not officially it was all done
unofficially at that time because they
weren't allowed to graduate Cambridge by
the way how far from London it's about
60 miles from London and what would it
be compared to in this country what kind
of a school what kind of a name is Yael
Harvard Princeton so he went to
Cambridge which was an elite it was an
elite school yeah he went to Cambridge
after they went to Kings College
he went to Kings College which was which
had been founded as an eat Eton
successor by the same King King Henry
the sixth who'd founded Eton had also
founded King's College Cambridge and so
Etonians
tended to go on to King's there by the
time Keynes was a
wheantr Kings they had to be good enough
to do that and they had to pass an
entrance exam and he got a scholarship
he got scholarships the whole time his
parents didn't need them they were quite
well-off by this time how many other in
the family kids had two two siblings
assist and a younger brother you talk
about when you in one of your
introductions about the widow and
friends problem for a biographer what is
the widow and friends problem well the
widow problem is the one that Roy Herod
faced we were talking about earlier you
know the widow doesn't want everything
told and the friends intimate friends
don't want everything revealed either
that's very natural I mean if you were I
so that if someone came around sort of
saying well ferreting in our lives after
we were dead we'd hope that someone
would protect us protect our memory a
little
and of course that's very natural after
50 years it doesn't matter really
and and then people do want to know more
and to know someone warts and all
actually makes them much more
interesting because we know enough now
about human nature to know that even our
heroes were not all perfect they weren't
all white they had dark sides and and
and and I think there's a demand so much
more accurate sensitive and
psychologically understanding biography
there used to be a hundred years ago
when everyone was put on a pedestal by
their biographers and nothing was
allowed to sully their original virtue
you have three books when did the first
one come out first one came out in
eighteen nineteen eighty-three and when
you first signed your contract could you
have a contract for three books no I had
a contract for one book to be delivered
within two years and how long did it
take to get all three of your books out
it took a year and so what happened well
partly my fault partly partly the
popular circumstances I found that very
very right of the right at the beginning
soon after the contract was signed the
papers I needed to look at I'd been told
they'd been available would be available
but they were closed they were closed to
various reasons some of them good some
of them not so good but they were closed
for five or six years after the contract
was signed and even though my the head
of my publishing firm Macmillan was the
former Prime Minister Harold Macmillan
and he wrote letters on my behalf to the
the the people at King's College
Cambridge where these papers were oh and
and and and in to Cambridge say look you
must let Robert Skidelsky in because you
know he's going to do a wonderful life
he couldn't make any impression at all
so for five or six years I couldn't do
anything so finally they were all
released in about 1978-79
and then I really started work then my
own particular dynamics came into play I
started writing the book
and I realize bye-bye 1980-1981 but I
was having a pretty pretty good volume
assembled but he's only covered the
first 30 years of his life that's right
silence said to my publishers hey let's
do three volumes and they sort of hummed
and hawed but agreed now this book was
published the last one that we're
talking about the third volume it was
published in this country in your
country win in 1990 I'm sorry the dude
current volume
yeah the current volume was published in
in in our country 1990 sorry in 2000 and
in the United States in 2001 how does it
fell how did so in Great Britain quite
well technically it was a best-seller
what that means for hardback books is
not a Jeffrey Archer or one of these I
mean it means that you know ten fifteen
thousand copies in hardback is a book of
this kind is reckoned to be a
best-seller and all three of these books
have been published in United States
that all three been published in the
United States how do they do here about
the same about the same this one we hope
may may do a bit better because it's got
a more American subject and it's had
more publicity than the others including
this program go back to his early days
came out of Cambridge in about what year
he left Cambridge in in nineteen hundred
and five Bloomsbury
what is Bloomsbury well Bloomsbury was a
it's a well known commune you might say
of writers and artists who started they
were called Bloomsbury because they
lived as young people in a particular
area of London known as Bloomsbury which
wasn't fashionable it's pretty
fashionable now where is it well it's
just yeah me know is he I don't know
whether you know
well one thinks of Piccadilly surfers as
sort of the centres just a little east
of it it's that way but it's not the
West End the West End was the
fashionable bit and Bloomsbury was a bit
East
it's like it was like it's like the
Dakota I suppose in in New York which
was so far away from the fashion that it
was called Dakota little bit yeah but it
sort of now it's very very fashionable
so they lived in that part of they lived
in that part of London these young
people two sisters Virginia and Vanessa
Stephens Virginia ven married Leonard
wolf and became Virginia Woolf
she's the best-known I suppose of the
pure Bloomsbury group people
Lytton Strachey Duncan grant Vanessa
Bell has sister who she married Clive
Bell and about seven or eight of them
and may be at odds and ends added
themselves on and they held the evenings
together they discussed literature life
they painted they wrote they lived a
rather bohemian they lived in a commune
they will have rooms and you know
they're in their house in the same sort
of Brut set of houses how long did that
go on what it really went on in that
form till the First World War
they were also very avant-garde they
were the people who really championed
the cause of post-impressionist painting
in England is that when maynard keynes
had his affair with her his relationship
with Duncan died it was in that period
yet how long did that go on well two or
three years I think the affair went on
about three years but they remained
lifelong friends and then Duncan grant
you see there was a bit of a
merry-go-round Duncan grant then sort of
became married though they never did get
married to Vanessa who was Virginia
Woolf sister and they lived together for
the rest of their lives
how known was this whole group back then
oh it was in little in the literary
world it was extremely well no impact
great yes on the way on the way I mean
Virginia Woolf was a novelist had an
enormous impact and in fact she is
studied today in all all literature
courses she's a she's a central figure
very much
um you know a kind of style of writing
which broke away from the straight
narrative and tried to capture moments
of time very in a way rather like
post-impressionism as well breaking away
from narrative in pictures break because
breaking it up into into moments either
either either bits of light or moments
of construction is the history of
blunder area available if you go to
wander now can you go to that area and
are there any museums or anything like
there there one or two blue blue plaques
on the on the walls of the houses which
commemorate the people who lived there
Maynard Keynes has got one number 46
Gordon Square which is where he made his
London home and where his widow went on
living as well as they also had a
country house there's a 1940 picture of
yellow in in Gordon Square I think
they're sitting there together it's
obviously winter there's snow behind
when did he get out of the Bloomsbury
crowd or in when it he marry Lydia
he married Lydia in 1925 he had been
having an affair with Lydia for four or
five years before they got married she
was already married to someone who had
been in there that's Lydia there's
actually rather beautiful picture of
them together in volume 2 I don't know
where wouldn't come to it maybe and she
was you know she'd been a member of the
Diaghilev Diaghilev ballet company which
was a famous Russian ballet company
which had left Russia before the
Revolution and Lydia spent quite a lot
of her a lot of her life in the United
States before the First World War
yeah yeah there's a there's an even
better one there they're sitting on
there sitting in the field in in the
fields just outside their house in the
country but that's where they got
married and Lydia was a brilliant dancer
absolutely brilliant dancer she was yeah
that's still another one
there's a whole there's a whole length
there's a ha a big half page proper half
page one of them somewhere along now she
is in a yeah there she is as Marussia in
in in in one of her famous ballet ballet
ballet rolls she was very lively very
vivacious dancer she was incredibly
incredibly pert and she spoke a very
peculiar kind of English which everyone
loved go when they got married what what
year was 1925 and what happened what was
the what was the reaction from the
Bloomsbury crowd they didn't like it too
much why not well they thought that
that's it that's I think you've got
that's the one of them together in the
early 1920s they thought that he wasn't
the marrying type
they thought that she wasn't the right
wife for him because as Virginia Woolf
said she didn't have a headpiece she was
a babbler she she couldn't they said she
couldn't argue consecutively these were
all rather intellectual people I mean we
call them blooms blue stockings in
England I'd anyway whether you've got
the same word in the United States
rather intellectual women's this was in
the early days nowadays you know all
women are meant to be intellectual but I
mean at that time intellectual women
were exceptional and women were expected
to be decorative decorative these
Bloomsbury women it was part of their
unconventionality they did things they
didn't dress as they were expected to
Lydia was more conventional but she was
more bohemian as well it was it was a
different combination they didn't they
didn't quite approve of her what about
the language her language her language
her language is absolutely wonderful why
why because she and she she she she she
used words deliberately incorrectly
deliberately yeah yeah why did she do
that in order to to create an effect
she spoke you know she'd been in America
for six years and should even been a
straight actress but she she liked to
she for example here's an example of
Lydia she comes to Canada in 1944
or with with with her husband there on a
finance
he's on a financial mission and Malcolm
MacDonald is the High Commissioner
British High Commissioner and so she
rushes out of the airplane before Keynes
and hugs him they'd never met and says
how wonderful to see you my dear my dear
mr. commissar she says commissar which
is of course the salt our Soviet
official or she knows Commissioner
perfectly well but she sort of
deliberately used it another occasion I
don't know whether I should tell this
story but it it was Dean Acheson or
Cordell how was giving an official
dinner at the State Department it's good
our whole Secretary of State and there
was a sudden law in the in the
conversation and Lydia was heard saying
to her next-door neighbor she said well
I understand how two men do it but two
holes making love it's quite it's quite
it's quite it's quite impossible two
women in other words so she she was
always very provocative in that in that
sort of way another famous Lydia
malaprop's was she was shown a
collection of birds by a hostess who was
very keen on her aviary and so she
showed Liddy around her collection of
birds and Lydia said says dear lady so
and so what a what wonderful ovaries you
have as she was always doing that that's
Russia it's a kind of Russian mischief
men not mischief-making but just sort of
a humor if you like the thing is that it
was her way of getting on in English
society because you know she was she was
moving with her husband in very high
circles by the time he was a top person
and she had to somehow
find a style for um you know making her
own way when did he get his period
you're his lordship he got his peerage
in 1942 who gave it during well
officially the king but on the
recommendation of Winston Churchill what
is what was his relationship we weren't
very good they got on extremely well
they were members of a dining club a
very exclusive dining club called the
other Club and right no it was to which
were elected people who were thought to
be intelligent amusing and they dined
once a month and during the war
Churchill who was one of the founder
members used to go as often as he could
and Keynes had been elected a member in
the 1920s and they often sat together
and talked conscientious objector in the
First World War he was a conscientious
objector those were his sentiments he
didn't actually um he wasn't actually
declared a conscientious objector
because he was anyway exempted from
having to fight by being at the Treasury
but he wrote out a letter of
conscientious objection to show
solidarity for his friend he wasn't a
pacifist Keynes and that would be wrong
some of the Bloomsbury people were
pacifist Keynes was not a pacifist he
didn't object to to having to fight was
he a socialist
no he wasn't a socialist he was a
liberal I think this is one of the
common mistakes made about Keynes often
people think he was a man he was a
socialist he he wrote many times and on
many occasions my theories are designed
to save the world from socialism not to
embrace socialism
what did Friedrich Hayek think of him
Friedrich Hayek thought he was the
cleverest man had ever met did he like
his policies do we have now he said he
didn't like his policies Bertrand
Russell also said one of the greatest
philosophers of the twentieth century
when I argued with Kay
as I felt I was taking my life into my
hands when he died what was his illness
and I know you say he was sick all his
life yeah well he died of what's called
a heart attack a coronary thrombosis
just suddenly one morning was it walked
up walk down the hill for from his house
it was a to his house and he was well he
felt well he felt better than he had for
many years he said and the next morning
he woke up there was a little coughing
his wife ran in his mother was staying
with him they both came in and after a
few few seconds he just fell back dead
and he was 63 just about to be 63 in
1946 yep I mean there's a lot that
you've written about him what was it
what was the toughest part of doing your
3 book series the toughest part was
undoubtedly the economics in but how did
you deal with generalist people like me
that you know that you get into a lot of
theory but there's an awful lot of
personal stuff how did you balance that
well I think that there two things
there's the private stuff
then there's the technical economics and
in between there's his journalism where
he is writing himself non technically
you know relationship with the New
Republic here in this country had a
relation with a New Republic in this
country he wrote a lot for the journal
called the nation in England he also
wrote a lot for The Times of London
London yes and and those were
non-technical expositions of his
economics how many books did he write ah
well how many books he wrote he wrote
four big books and lots of pamphlets he
wrote in 1925 one of his best
one of his best things was a short view
of Soviet Russia
he went to Soviet Russia just after he
married Lydia and wrote saying that this
was a most awful Society and no one
could possibly be a communist who hadn't
suffered some horrible conversion that
had overturned all the decent values
that people have
has the Keynesian revolution past us no
it's not past us
yeah when after the 11th of September
your President George W Bush sent a
stimulus bill to Congress stimulus bill
straight pain economy they felt the
economy was possibly already in
recession that the 11th of September
might have worsened the recession so
they sent a spending tax cutting measure
to Congress that was the reaction now
that shows also some of the problems of
doing that kind of thing because by the
time our much watered down version of
the stimulus bill we've actually passed
a couple of days ago for a week ago the
economy had it was already on the men so
you know it may be too stimulating as it
turns out so I think this is these are
some of the problems but the reaction
was appeal Keynes in reaction we don't
have much time but I want to read this
from your preface American readers might
be shocked by the revelation in these
pages of the bitterness of
anglo-american rivalry yes shocked
shocked because well because you know
Britain's the loyal ally Britain there's
a special relationship you know you can
really rely on the Brits America was
very anti British in the 1930s and that
lasted through much of the war though
because Britain was still a great power
and it may have been the going power and
the America was the coming power but the
going power had quite a lot going for it
still and until that issue was resolved
and Britain declined sufficiently really
for it not to be a rival of the United
States and after the Cold War started
and Russia was identified the Soviet
Union as the main enemy then of course
the special relationship started to
flourish especially on the military and
intelligence side but it was always more
important to the British than to the
Americans by the way are there any
keynes
Keynes's left relatives great oh of
Keynes's i thought you were going to say
people like Keynes
yeah they're lots of games is they
didn't have any children but his brother
had four children were you interested
various people yes yes I know most of
them quite well and what's the advantage
of knowing whether well they were able
to tell stories tell stories about about
about their uncle who they're known as
young people also one got a flavor of
the family its dynamics its psychology
is there a statute of john maynard
keynes anywhere in Great Britain is
there there's I'm sure there's a the
busts of him in Cambridge but there's no
full-length statue there are no statues
of economists statues of economists very
rare maybe there'll be more of them in
the 21st century I there are if you go
back if you went to Great Britain can
you find a place that said a room or a
big painting of his of him yeah in his
here you know where do you how prominent
is he there now in his old college those
are there that they're good paintings of
him there's a famous painting which I
reproduce a bit of it is on the front
cover of my second volume by William
Roberts which actually that's it and and
that's a painting it's only a section
his wife is his on his left that's
that's a well-known painting there one
or two busts there are there's a famous
painting of him as a young man by Duncan
grant which is on the cover of the first
volume which is this is when they were
having their affair and they were
staying in an art in on an island off of
the coast of Scotland and Keynes was
writing his book that's the way he used
to write he used to have a writing board
and he had right he was writing at a
treatise on probability and Duncan grant
was painting Robert Skidelsky we're out
of time this is the cover of the book
and it's through the third of three
volumes on John Maynard Keynes fighting
for freedom thank you very much for
joining us